das ist durch deren ehren hallo mein
name ist lucanet meine mutter ruft mich
gerade an mama ich nehme gerade auf ich
rufe dich gleich zu herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video blablabla
luca ist dumm und sein handy
auszustellen programm zu bieten die im
test home zufall
die internetmedien testing games wir
befinden uns heute nämlich auf einer
website auf der es fünf verschiedene
idiotentest leute mal ganz kurz
wenn das video gerade rauskommt ist der
erste sechste das heißt die neuen
produkte gibt es sehr viele stiftung.de
ich hoffe mal ich habe dieses video
jetzt irgendwie so gegen 14 uhr
rausgehauen
deswegen sage ich das einmal ganz kurz
leute im shop sind heute die neuen
produkte drin also diese basecap das
cover des songs lied ein bißchen
bettwäsche noch ein pink gehört ich habe
da schon viel zu viel werbung für
gemacht ihr findet den link zu meinem
job und in der beschreibung check das
gern mal aus in einer stunde also um 15
uhr launischen die sachen und jetzt
fangen wir an mit denen idiotentest wir
fangen direkt an mit idiotentest nummer
eins und zwar werde ich so machen dass
wenn ich bei diesen idioten test jetzt
eine frage falsch beantwortet dass ich
direkt weiter machen muss mit
idiotentest nummer zwei das heißt wenn
ich sehr klug binden könnte dieses video
hier sehr sehr lange gehen wenn ich
allerdings sehr drum bin dann ist das
video relativ schnell vorbei und ich
glaube zweiteres ist eher der fall
simply clever und der square to begin
das heißt ich klicke auf square erpresst
the big red button to continue ich denke
den großen knopf press rectangle to
continue the green button also
rot-rot-grün presse blue button free
times denn die ohren sportheims also 1
bei 3
was
muss sich den blauen knopf vier mal
drücken
wir machen weiter mit idiotentest nummer
zwei kommt es dem kläger die number one
to continue das heißt ich blicke auf die
1 klick und die nonne vor ort und können
süchtig auf die vier legal director
contini richtige auf das dingens press
play button to continue klick auf den
button presse die happy face der ist
hier also dass hier to continue presse
das ist dieses hier jetzt soll ich das
bild von dem hund anklicken jetzt soll
ich den kreis anklicken
katja preß were twice das heißt 12 ort
ist das happy face zwei plus zwei ist
hier
ich dachte schon ich ja verkauft aber
hier steht die square klickten und weiß
das heißt 12 kontinuität exakte wurde
schauen also okay
triangle abriss ist glaube ich das hier
don't click anything steht hier jetzt
mike craig sei okay
ich fühle mich schon nicht so dumm jetzt
euch die weintrauben anklicken der
circle to continue the way to go ich bin
jetzt schon dann ist das hier
wieder geschafft
ich würde gar nicht so tun wie man denkt
denn dort weiß also so und nochmal die
vier press die triangle presse triangle
dem direkten the circle also 12
o
[Musik]
herr 2000 jahre später
a
jetzt verstehe ich das auch
normalerweise war ich immer darauf
getrimmt das wäre nicht auf irgendwas
darauf klickte sich die teile verändern
aber ich hätte diesmal dann wirklich auf
das nächste objekt klicken müssen also
fock machen weiter mit dem dritten test
wenn euch das video hier bei dabei
gefällt dann würde ich mich selber
unlike freuen weil eine live zeigt mir
dass ich vielleicht doch nicht so dumm
bin wie ich denke
als erstes müssen wir den gelben button
drücken jetzt den roten jetzt den blauen
jetzt den grünen jetzt den grünen noch
mal jetzt den blauen den blauen noch mal
congratulations ich habe das erste level
schon geschafft jetzt das square dance 3
engel jetzt die vier dass der größte
grüne kreis das orange gelb blau grün
button
[Musik]
ich dachte was bleibt da stehen ich weiß
aber dass da stand yellow button sei sie
dann irgendwas wird auch fortschritt wir
machen weiter mit ihr testen bevor
presse green button to continue yellow
und dann blau orange weiß denn der red
hot orange orange press preview button
die online-sparte newron hier sind schon
klug der yonex die farben verdreht also
press the green triangle worden ich
dachte immer noch das eingeblendete
green triangle ich glaube rote triangle
sollte mir das genauer durchlesen in der
tat kommen wir jetzt zu den idiotentest
der nicht als nummer fünf abgestempelt
wird sondern als ultimate ist also
presse green button konnten relativ easy
jet press die yellow button to continue
nun den orangenen knopf drücken
yes
in der tat ich werde mich diesmal ein
bisschen mehr konzentrieren also
presserat denn blue also rot und dann
blau erpressen wolle sebastian pini das
ist der gelbe hier der boss edipresse
largest button das ist der grüne present
the green broadways länderrat grün grün
rot jetzt dreimal orange zweimal also
gelb gelb gelb orange orange weißen
strand great time square wo also bei dem
letzten muslim ich gerade sehr doll
anstrengend ich bin jetzt schon sehr
dumm also wir kriegen aber weiter auf
continue soll jetzt sind smart 3d ist
zwei mal grün also bei grün 1 januar
drei blau das kann jetzt mehr merken ein
paar sekunden später also grün zwei mal
yello einmal und laute dreimal
wow
ich bin gar nicht mal so dumm
dass du die hauptaussage dieses videos
ich realisiere dass ich doch nicht so
hart umbindet
also jetzt soll ich das viereck zweimal
anklicken dann das dreieck zweimal und
an den kreis also 12 12 und jetzt den
kreis so what is for worldwide page
[Musik]
egal
es ist eigentlich der buchstabe h die
sache ist aber dass bei solchen kurs ist
irgendwie immer alles ein bisschen ort
ist also ich klicke jetzt aber trotzdem
noch die latte age das hat geklappt
abfluss lieben - zwei sind 15 sind 13
der drossel lucky als nächstes haben
geht zweimal 16 klassiert sind 60 45 das
die serc square denn die triangle also
kreis dreieck wo ich wünsche fast
durchschnitt jetzt soll ich das atomare
symbol für kupfer darstellen also ich
glaube das ist die prestige cars were
tri teams erwartet kreis square
friedrich 31
bei 31 walter ich schlage mich grad mega
gut mathe bin ich eigentlich immer ganz
gut also 4 -3 sind 1 2 x 122 x 7 sind 14
hautnah dreimal zehn sind 30 - 13 sind
17 osim ich bin deutsch schnell machen
freue ich mich sogar im durchschnitt rot
grün gelb also rot grün
das ist nicht der
da unten wirklich und auch das ding
drauf dass tricky trabbis rot blau
orange gelb rot blau orange gelb geld
bar
ich bin keine smart presste buttons in
the following oder rot 231 als rot blau
gelb und 22 rot blau gelb rot blau grau
alter schwede ich habe das gefühl dass
ich echt nicht so
ich würde dieses video am liebsten schon
längst beenden weil schon voll lang gilt
aber dass ich darf doch nicht weil ich
immer noch drin bin das dreieck zweimal
anklicken dann den kreis drei mal und
dann den blauen
wer also bloß wer am ende kreis drei
wochen später 1 21 23 und jetzt das die
amazing ich bin klug
stolz auf mich blau-grün zweimal orange
rot blau grün zweimal orange rot das
sind frei das sind sechs mal dass waisen
12 das sind 14 remake des presseamtes
morris button to continue
diese kleinen [ __ ] hier 12
[Musik]
ich weiß diesmal wirklich nicht was ich
falsch gemacht haben aber leute ich kann
auf jeden fall sagen dass ich krank
smart bin also so schlecht wie ich das
jetzt nicht einstufen die zu beginn
schon gesagt gibt es nun mehrere neue
produkte neue lukasz ob ich würde mich
freuen wenn ich einfach mal
vorbeischauen würde
und sonst würde ich an dieser stelle
auch dass wir beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich sehr freuen und ihr findet die
jetzt hier eine smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren da oben findet ihr
auch schon wie gerade schon erwähnt
meinen shop eingeblendet in dem heute
die neuen klamotten gelaunt sind bunt
hier unten ist ein weiteres video
verlinkt so checkt ist start und in den
nächsten
sechs tagen kommen blogs